the paris agreement was signed by 196
countries in 2015 and the deal was this
try to limit global warming to well
below 2 degrees preferably to 1.5
degrees above pre-industrial levels it's
the focus of all climate action
everywhere but are we past the point of
no return already so kate to you first
of all at the moment according to the un
current global action plans
are prompting a rise in emissions that's
what they're predicting so are is it
possible to keep this idea of 1.5 alive
do you think
yes absolutely i think that we need to
be absolutely clear that the climate
climate crisis is definitely coming to a
head the time is up we know that
governments need to act now and you know
what they're promising right now simply
isn't enough
the cuts are needed and this has to
change in glasgow i think every country
in the world knows what needs to be done
and they just need to get on with it
what we hear from boris johnson and
let's face it the uk has a special role
in being the uk president of the cops we
need to be leading by example and what
we've heard this year is a lot of talk a
lot of targets and very little action
whatsoever across all sectors and we
really need that to change both at home
and around the world stu i've seen you
nodding a lot there i suggest you might
not as well to what antonio guterres un
secretary general has said as well then
much bolder climate action is needed is
essentially what he's saying there and
the energy transitions commission has
put out a report with six actions that
it says can keep 1.5 alive but we know a
lot of it don't we already what is going
to make the difference and make people
act do you think
well i think first of all keeping 1.5
alive is really important because that
for me as a consumer if i if i feel
we're getting there we can get there i
can buy into it i agree with everything
kate said there but we've got to see
strategic plans for every government
department whether that be on
agriculture energy transport we've
really got to see action uh on the
ground we've got to see uh we've got to
start to reduce our reliance our
addiction on fossil fuels take those big
actions as kate said and i'm fully
behind everything she just touched on
well and the government will probably
say we've got more plans to be revealed
coming down the line as we heard from
hannah thomas peter earlier on but it's
interesting you talked about personally
buying into something i just
um stuart kate what do you think i mean
is this all about governments and
corporations doing their bit or can we
make a difference as individual
consumers briefly if you can
i think it's individual consumers that's
really important but also as individual
campaigners we can all take action um
through ngos like greenpeace who are
also calling on
urgent action from governments and we
can all have a part to play not just as
consumers but as as political beings if
you like there's a lot to do and
everyone needs to take part and the
quick word in 10 seconds stuart do you
agree individuals can make a difference
i i do i do and politicians do but also
the parts of the economy such as farming
with our net zero 2040 we're already
there and we want to go further